ladies and gentlemen the Boston kid and
Bryan Callen are back we carry for
anybody that kid you're the kid
yeah Boston you're the Boston I'm still
pump I don't know I mean you know from
what I heard you tore up the Wilbur it
went good man the Boston who the [ __ ] do
you think you are
he's up and up in this [ __ ]
good good weekend I I had the pleasure
asked me what I did yesterday that's
when I was doing yesterday on Sunday
tailpiece hunter Moscow do you feel like
talking to ed Solomon wrote he wrote men
in black and a bunch of great movies I
was like yeah of course things with Will
Smith minimum yeah he wrote he's huge
writer and great guy
and he goes but but I want to put him
together with this quantum physicist and
them spiro me helices I was like that's
an interesting Sunday I mean all right
a navvy Sunday it's a heavy Sunday
because Spiro Miha lacus who is 38 6-4
through the javelin Greek handsome but
well let me let me let me just give you
a little tease I saw your Instagram
video yeah it didn't make much sense but
let me give you a little teaser because
there is a there's a there's a there are
10 questions out there that physicists
consider the questions that will solve
the universe you know like okay of
everything yeah the theory of everything
there you go
the theory of everything all right here
you because you have thank you for
knowing that you have the Newtonian
reality we live in gravity and all that
then there's a quantum reality which is
the subatomic reality we're [ __ ] you
know everything is on its head time
doesn't make time is relative its bed
space doesn't you know all this stuff
dimensions so there there's a question
call dining halls the the quantum Hall
the quantum hall promising anything
right now the people of one Nobel Prizes
people have won Nobel prizes and won
fields medals in mathematics which you
get a million-dollar prize for for
making progress on the problem they've
met solve ah yeah so they've read
written in teams they've written books
on it
sure this gentleman a 38 solved the
problem
where'd he go to college uh he went to
well he was at four he was a prodigy at
four years old playing the piano no no
no he had four years old he was I mean
he was out doing math and his mom was
helping him with her older his other
older brother and the kid looked at it
and goes but forgoes know just do this
this and that
and they were like what see married
family well he's got a girl not a family
he's completely normal
yeah it's so weirdly normal first of all
he was an athlete so his dad he was
trained to be it was gonna throw the
javelin for the Olympics so his dad was
training but if you look at him he's
like this big guy loves to play beach
volleyball lives down in Manhattan Beach
like not a nod not quote unquote
scientist more of a dude is more of a
philosopher but what's funny is it he
solved the problem he solved this yeah
now he's now they're taking like they
said they're gonna take three years with
this team there's no like I don't know
six people in the world who can tell
make sure that he's right okay so it'll
take about three years awesome that's
cool yeah dealing with this very very
like the nature of existence like their
very nature of existence and he talks
like this he goes like this I'm trying
to have a conversation with a guy like
that who's funny and will talk to you
about philosophy and every matters is
good yeah yeah but he's kind of
recognized as in many ways like a
modern-day Einstein like one of the
smartest people in the world who will
win a Nobel Prize and probably the
Fields Medal in mathematics you should
have brought him to Boston should have
brought him to use doing boxing he
should open up for me a Boston butt but
like but like he talks about stuff like
this he goes I mean at the end of the
day you know it's the the existence
doesn't really exist and there is no
time and we have come to the conclusion
that really even even the idea of your
place anywhere is not real so we should
all just commit suicide I know I go I go
I go so can you please explain what this
[ __ ] means to me like what are you
guys saying who really delve in the
majors like this he goes I guess the
best way to describe it is you know yeah
have you ever put on the goggles for
virtual reality and you feel like you're
in there and sometimes if you're as well
yeah you know they can make things like
you can make you cold with air and I go
yeah that would probably be the best way
to describe what we believe existence is
for us so we are looking at things that
are with goggles on but you know I go so
if I die maybe that not a conspiracy
theory it's not a conspiracy theory it's
it's actually what they're proving with
math I can't raise it they're proving it
with math and he goes and and nothing is
true everything is true depending yeah I
don't I can't deal with that [ __ ] no I
would even math isn't true because like
even like because unless you're dealing
with space curve time I'm like I don't
know too much room on it I'm out I
tapped out when the two minutes in the
story I said I go how how do you walk
around in your life and he goes I know I
go down the rabbit hole goes by at the
end of the day it's all [ __ ] yes
because I started to make the trains run
on time I start to eat well no I was
dude you missed all the time Boston man
yeah I did huh
you missed a good time we that when I
got stage went which Brian was here man
said to my brother was the only thing
missing so did I that crowd when Rogen
hit that stage I mean I'll see a few
people figure it out yeah kept hinting
it went crazy they went no because they
didn't know for sure they had no idea
like I'd say nine percent had no idea
20th they went wow you and but he didn't
wait I was gonna have them announce go
and now for your opening act Joe Rogan
and then Joe he hits the stage but
they're like you ready to go and I was
like yeah he's gonna kill you up and
Rogan just [ __ ] beeline to the stage
so he goes what's HAP you [ __ ] freaks
yeah yeah Oh like oh my god video oh my
god he probably did 30 something minute
daily 35 minutes damn and I did an hour
damn that's man it's such a good that's
not such a good vibe and then Ron goes
dude we should do a Q&A together
afterwards but that'd be fun well yeah
remember some it's Boston
I didn't our Road it 3040 minutes
they've been there for bin they're wild
there's their drinking it's a great
crowd great crowd yeah but then when you
do a Q&A it's me and Rogan gets a little
crazy yep and this one guy with a scarf
on decide to heckle Rogen and he's in
the front and Rogan destroyed this guy
so bad is set the vibe of
so then people shout out things you know
rolling them back down he just like [ __ ]
you I mean just roasting these people so
what Fred we had a few questions but I
was like my q and A's typically aren't
like that it was fun but I was like
fighting with everybody it was funny
though no no no it was entertaining
though like the guy with the scarf just
felt like complete [ __ ] and then he was
in my VIP meet-and-greet
guys the scarf II put I can tell the
before you to me hides the scarf I'm
like your scarf guy hugging us I'm
hammered man I'm sorry I love ball T I
didn't mean that a lot of that's what
they are a lot of guys just love you and
they just get you know they get a little
crazy there's this picture I should have
posted it's when the guy starts heckling
Rodian I'm like we're ball on stage I'm
like this and Rogen's like you he has
that intense stare you stand down how
it's almost like this what was he saying
to him ah [ __ ] you Rogen get off the
state like just like what like something
like that yeah like what are you
thinking
what in the world will meet you halfway
oh my god it was totally a half whale is
hilarious yeah I thought stand up for me
best best night of my life
yeah the milestone man well the Wilbur
theater is also epic it doesn't really
get bigger than that I mean you can talk
about Stadium but that's all [ __ ]
because there's nothing like the Wilbur
theater when it's packed like that
special brought comic I don't believe
there's a better room I actually don't
so I mean you can talk about the Chicago
theater I did that with Rogen is 3500
people it's not the same energy the
laughter rolls you know I did fight it
50 minutes like and it was a great set
as much doesn't matter I'd way rather do
the Wilbur theater you will the way it's
set up it's almost like three separate
it's also got hitting see it it's so
cool look at that look at that it was so
freaking when I was in college I got up
on stage after seeing a show in DC
remember thinking I just want to taste
this one time to Wilbur but just know it
was like but but yeah the Wilbur's had a
historic beautiful feels a good night
man just a bunch of people came out like
Coach John Kavanagh oh yeah Connor said
coaches there
I made up a ton of people does the ring
card girls were all there it's just the
support was cool cool cool cool
but before show especially it was weird
it almost felt like a almost like a
fight with the nerves cuz I get nervous
for stand-up but I never have any issues
sleeping nothing like that and there's
some other stuff I'm dealing with
outside the comedy space that I was
dealing with but the the night before I
couldn't sleep well I was like Donna
you've been doing this for a very long
period of time on and off and I was like
tomorrow's a big one then you know the
Boston crowd is notoriously known for
being a little rough like Boston I'll
turn on you Boston attorney super quick
and so I was a little nervous about that
like I believe in what I'm doing I've
been all over the world doing it but
Boston is a different vibe man you
suppose worried about that and you got
Rogan then I'd show time filming a bunch
of stuff there during the show and then
there's just all these in-house like oh
[ __ ] I feel like I'm about to you'll
find him all night and then I then I
called you and you're like well you
could be fighting Francis or steep a
tomorrow night you could be dealing with
those there's alright that's a great
point yeah yeah I could be calling right
now then how you feeling and remember I
was scared scared scared and your your
voice would be like this scared and
rather be anywhere else
hating it before every five not talking
by how you feeling man
scared but I'd rather do anything else
right now but I got to do this tomorrow
hello not in your nature no how much
better is to be I don't have Rogan open
for me at the Wilbur sold out do some
stand-up hey Dan Mahli yeah he made some
decent money I would venture to say more
than you made fighting career I call me
crazy call me I mean I know the Reebok
contracts big but still you know you
don't say um and then I went to the win
for the fights on Saturday night your
hopefully went to look your tweet about
[ __ ] the UFC training center made me
laugh I will get into the oh my god you
called that to a tee by the way but
we'll get into that that day though we
walked around Boston Chile Boston freeze
Oh it'll it'll it'll hurt your face
freezing it'll hurt job blew it to a
restaurant down to this boy stur bar
place we looked it up as like top five
places deep
walked in cane and his whole crews
eating there it's small place pat gonna
bail it's okay mr. mr. Velasquez there
he was their kind none of those maybe
look on that one but yeah because I
wouldn't think we're either bar would be
he neither dude I'm telling you I had
the might be Union Oyster House keep
going though nope keep going keep it
rolling
keep going Oh Neptune really yep so so
yeah it's a small place packed at the
clam chowder but I had the lobster roll
dude really this thing was in [ __ ]
said top five meals ever had in my life
Wow top five damn top five eight that
walked around we went on you to love
that [ __ ] the Paul Revere trail woman
saw Paul Revere's house I wouldn't like
that but you wouldn't I don't know I
don't feel like she liked that Paul
Revere trail have freedom trails you
don't I mean there's so much there's a
lot of history there yeah it's cool yeah
I love boss I'm up I love Boston man I
love love Bonnie it's works
this country's clean it's not as busy
traffic as that's great I'm gonna eat
there but then oh that's why I didn't
tell you so I've been dealing with that
stomach issue haven't had coffee in two
weeks now I'm having coffee here that
I've been taking all that no no yes I
acid medicine you know that every throw
up immediately
so haven't thrown up in a quite some
time since the Golden Globes after
Golden Globes I threw up so I'm good
doing the VIP mean great hasn't eaten in
a while and I guess when you don't eat
it builds up acid in your stomach which
is an issue for me I didn't know that
but it's hard for me before shows I just
didn't eat so I'm going through the meet
and greets the VIPs and we're about 6300
I start to sweat and hey guys can tell
when it when it's about to hit and I go
oh man here we go how many left they go
41 very cool very cool so you can tell
the pictures like one eyes open when I
shut my mouth is salivating are you
sweating like a [ __ ]
that's I was in here before I throw up
yep we get done we're all in the car
gone but going back it's like Rogan Todd
Jamie Britney Palmer were dropping her
off at her hotel and went there driving
I'm like oh man it's about the hit and
someone's talking and I just go my mouth
fills up with throw-up oh you know what
she's gonna swallow it because we should
be stopping a minute that's just good I
just don't know if I still throwing bomb
it well that makes you more say oh yeah
that's good feeling so then Todd goes oh
[ __ ] Brens about to hurl so I just glide
past Rogan I do like a somersault pass
row again yep on the highway get out I
hurl everywhere yeah everywhere and what
did Rogan do Rodan gets out of the car
it's not a car and examined me throwing
up and goes let's talk crouch down and
he was really concerned kiddies how many
times you start up I go weekly weekly
not stop yeah you've seen doctor what no
no too busy see a dog ITEX Brennan I go
how well the doctor said is just too
busy Bryce sure didn't see him too busy
I gotta go really gotta go see one by Li
again I leave downstairs how many issues
are confusing to like because a lot of
times doctors will be like mmm yeah well
could be a bacterial thing could be an
acid thing that's what they say to you I
I've been to doctors for that stuff and
they're like no I definitely see a
doctors maybe they can figure it out me
put a tube down there's something so you
something I don't know what to do though
because it's not good like I'm
constantly not feeling great all the
time so it's not good have you tried a
knot crackers and [ __ ] chugged pepto
bismal have you tried and this is not
even an ad for it but I when I was
nauseous and I took that total gut
health I took it for like a week and it
cured me no way
I wonder if the other day miss balance
in your gut like a bacterial balance to
last this long low and since I've
stopped coffee and I've stopped real at
Civic acidic food yep it should be going
away but I don't know I need to see a
doctor I really do I just don't know
when I'm gonna do it yeah but but I feel
like can't you control it when you eat
like are you because you're eating you
said you hadn't eaten
I had me I mean I hate that giant
the best meal in my life oh you didn't
that got me through you know to whenever
but what time was it the last time you
eat that's like - and then yeah well
that's that's eight hours yeah and it's
nothing but acid I know it does throw up
off that's weird um not necessarily I've
never had the frass all the time
remember yeah
no coffee your body changes as you get
[ __ ] older bro that I need to see a
doctor straight up let me see a guest
guest ah yes gasps yes troll gastronomic
tunnel a stomach doc I have the guy okay
Tommy doctor I gave you his number I
need to tell me doc you need Tommy
doctor you mom Tommy dad yeah hey Doc
you got a bum tummy I gotta figure it
out man got some swirly stuff going on
him at UM oh yeah Tom went to the fights
aisle Tara was interesting as were in
the car headed to the fights I'm
thinking I remember it put me puts me in
a weird space you know brings back
memories because I was in the car and
we're going to the the arena I remember
being in that same exact car headed to
arena just like that never found Boston
Vaughn New Jersey or anywhere but you're
in those same cars and you're headed
there and you're watching people like
live their lives and you're gonna find
another grown man in the cage it's such
a weirdo we and it brought me an extreme
brought me back to that just be like god
I might I'd be in that car spike oh my
god what am i doing man yeah and you're
looking at me like god I wish I was them
just strolling around having a nice meal
hanging out
but yeah so I get kind of quiet my
brother and Todd knew right away I get
kind of quiet but then went to the guard
I forget what's called that something
garden down there what is it
TD guard to guard and yeah TD Garden
with the boss self explain yeah went
there we got there just in time for the
main card not a great card not a great
great card at all matter of fabric are
another good card at all but I and I'll
be the first one to say I was dead wrong
about Francis thing got it hold on he's
dead wrong I was dead Brian was spot-on
well you're hilarious yeah your tweet I
had also I had the benefit of hearing
from other people who trained with
Francis that his striking wasn't as
high-level very powerful but but but a
little bit telegraphy so I had that
beneficial
the data light so well this isn't a
benefit but I had this from the most
legit source you can think of without
giving away their name okay that after
the fight it came out that Francis
decided not to do any wrestling for this
candle he thought he was just gonna walk
in there and knock Steve a out in the
first round without any wrestling or
grappling yes I do no wrestling just
striking a dlc institute he only hit
mitts what what see that that's very
strange because your tweet really made
me laugh we were like um does the UFC
training center not have wrestling or
treadmills I was dying your wrestling
his zero cardio just was not there was
what was right when it sir I was so
nervous so nervous for steeping yeah
don't you twist it yeah I'm I'm always
written with steeping he bay is a friend
of my Steve a was form a training
partner I was rootin for steep a I did
not think he was gonna win this fight
I'll be the fish because Francis is such
a liability in the beginning yeah and
she does eat shots and steep a ticket
hit but it did not matter steep a is the
greatest heavyweight of all time yeah so
when I was watching try I'm gonna
contend I I'm looking forward together
so when steep a first shot in and I saw
you know in Francis pushed Tomas stuff
like that it what I look for is the
technique where's his foot placements
hips and his hair and placement is that
know what oh he didn't know how to
wrestle
mmm-hmm when I was like was over him
hoop trying to pin him against the cage
and he quickly reversed it that's what
that's not wrestling really
but then when when steep a shot in I saw
there's no sway yeah yeah oh oh he has
no rest no I looked at my brother he I
went oh he's [ __ ] and my buddy Todd my
agent bets on all the fights and he took
steep a and I go you're gonna win and
this is probably two three minutes in
the fight oh you're gonna win man by
decision I bet yeah by decision yeah
I actually I walked out during the begin
the fourth round we all got up and left
and well I'm leaving the crowds like
what got [ __ ] the shop do so soon oh
this one's all over fellas everyone can
leave this one's oh it was yeah and and
I I there couple things I went through
my own one was that that he's been
fighting only for four years which
I didn't realize how short of a time yes
a freak athlete but when I was watching
him what little I know about just also
foot placement when you're throwing
shots very powerful he's got that he
throws that not technical bringing that
I wouldn't even I don't mean to
interrupt you I would even know are you
I don't think he's a once-in-a-lifetime
athlete no I don't think that I hear you
I think that's I would hear you that
just incredibly powerful with a lot of
fast I think you I think years old and I
don't know how much faster is muchly
muscly as compared to NFL athlete now
okay and I know it sounds like dude roll
up on it I was you saw you know you saw
him until he beat our last game over him
I wasn't on the train before that went
he's Jango's braids I remember I mean
Rogan are you I don't know yeah I don't
think he's once a lifetime athlete after
seeing that and yeah even even before
when he defended takedowns when he would
lunge and throw that right you know it
what is that right I know I I don't
think he's ones do is he a good athlete
correct
could he compete in the NFL not a
[ __ ] shot nowhere near the athlete
none of those guys yeah not even close
after I saw that the way he his anti
wrestling his cage work his cardio his
explosiveness how that went straight out
the window and put it right out the
window within the first two minutes yes
and now people go oh let's not write out
Francis it's not that I'm writing
Francis off it's a blueprint you saw
pretty you saw a very clear blueprint
for how to beat him every time correct I
mean if you're not gonna wrestle I'll
just take you down I talked to her doom
I'm not dr. doom while we were there and
I went man I hope you get the winner he
was yes yes yes yes and after seeing
that I went oh well the blueprints out
even if I'm not a world-class wrestler I
can take Francis down I could have one
year of wrestling in high school he's
intro that's right little loan a guy
like this guy who's got apples ass shop
I think for Duke I looked you bring up
the the you bring up the rankings it's
not a pretty picture for that not at all
unless they give them the exact matchups
he needs it's gonna I wouldn't suggest I
would even suggest and steep a did this
stay west waiting at the edge of the
pocket when Francis does those lunging
like lunging shot like
whom will you step back boom laughs yes
he's in almost nothing yes he did
and and he'll get knocked out too III
think that that it was very clear that
he's had four years of fighting and
maybe not even the greatest tutelage
he's just so powerful that he got by on
that but I think a lot of guys are gonna
figure do I know you want to know what
else is alarming his corner his corner
forgot his water and stool differ guys
was they just put towels on him in
between rounds Wow
and then it so when I was fighting if I
told my my corner man oh we're not doing
any wrestling this camp I'm fighting I'm
fighting Nogueira
or I'm fighting you know name on an
all-american I didn't know Stevie was
all-american d1 did you know that yeah
yeah it's Cleveland State I don't know
if he was all-american heard he was
all-american you look that up Cleveland
say he's a d1 wrestler what I know is a
d1 wrestler yeah but if I told my
coaches hey we're not doing in grappling
but you're fine dress it I know I'm a
knocking out they went you're [ __ ]
you're out of your mind yeah you're out
of your the matter of fact were
increased our grappling cuz that's his
best chance to win yes we know so hard
you hit yes the whole thing is strange
to me the whole thing is like I I and he
got he got found out he fought a high
level you know um Division one wrestling
right
yeah but not but I don't think he was
all-american I heard he was I don't
think Steve tell me that but he might be
wrong Eve yeah I don't think way to go
eat you keep going to oh no go up go up
I saw it
hold on the rest are clear estate yeah I
know he's a Gold Glove champion no he
was in division very good boxing yeah
out struck him in PL struck him but um
and it was so funny how I mean I was
surprised I have zero problems being
wrong again this is why a lot of
analysts I don't refer to myself as an
analyst was like well you guys don't
make picked because they don't want to
blow back I don't give a [ __ ] right I
don't care man right I don't care
Oh job you show wrong oh I thought you
knew what you're talking about oh oh my
bad
I had no I not yeah I had no idea
Frances just plays grab-ass of the UFC
Institute he's just I had no idea he
hits mitts and [ __ ] grabs everyone's
cheeks while rolls through the office
right I had no idea he doesn't
wrestle yeah I'd know cool no idea he
was doing zero probably zero cardio work
right I mean he got he's so sweet he
look at his drunk I was like I know I
don't want to be disrespectful to him
but he's that I like he looked he looked
it's okay to be critically so exhausted
exhausted and you know it was stupid his
mindset so steep a may have had an
adrenaline dump like he got hit I don't
know what happened but I get out of ruin
your cardio when I'm here like that
sucks up your cardio why is that it's
just that the recovering the energy
right to compose yourself have come back
like it's hard to get your breath sure
hitting rock sure [ __ ] up your car so
and you didn't hit by the hardest man in
the world cause you get nervous you're
terrified how about when Dana goes give
steeper the belt and see buddy grabs it
and gives it to his coach wow wow can
you felt you know I think he felt
disrespected I felt like he thought that
the UFC was you know brighting and dying
on Francis kinda they put all their eggs
in his basket now to the UFC's defense
ste paid to me is the greatest
heavyweight in the UFC of all time but
he's never been that huge paper you draw
so how do you get the guy to be the big
draw I do the same thing I did with Aldo
do they need they need a rivalry right
they need something like that so you
build up the contender to try and sell
those pay-per-view so I get what they're
doing there but man you gotta you gotta
may take care of the champ I'll tell you
who's gonna beat steep a cane that's
right and I'll tell you why he's gonna
beat steep a Cain's a better wrestler or
as good a wrestler cane I believe that a
red striker is a better rep and I think
and and we all know the cardia tired and
is the only problem with that and I
agree with these style-wise if it's a
healthy cane yeah is a nightmare
yeah okay but if you compare steep base
record to canes
I think steep a right now is the best
use of heavyweight of all times
everybody
yeah finishes everyone and you look at
this roster and then what he did to
Frances
yeah you know one thought he could do
all that stuff and he's the most
successful you'll see champion of all
time you know that every way to vote
them the most successful but Kane's
injuries right are so bad you know he's
a cage around the spine I didn't know
that I didn't know you know it's hard
for me try
a ton back to that's a huge problem
that's a Hugh and I heard that for a
bomber night when I heard he said like
he has a cage around it's mine
wow that's a big problem that's a real
big problem I don't know what that you
know I mean now let's say that does it
know that matters and he can train
full-time yeah and we have a hundred
percent came through some presets eBay
I think came does everything that Steve
a does a little better yes sir why Sarah
why I think I need a healthy care in his
courier ran off with the best of all
time but due to injuries ste base had a
better career you got to give it on
that's why Steve pays number and you do
have to put in to account I think I
think I think if steepen came or to
fight soon Steve a beat them yeah
because they have to hearing that yeah
cuz can can't train the way you used to
because Kane has a cage around spine
because they're a lot although all the
years it's built up and he it's hard for
me train and he's injured and yeah we
don't know how much he wants to do it
anymore and there's all this stuff that
builds up so but he was there right he
was in Boston Horner and Daniel he's in
the back corner Daniel okay you know but
he is gonna fight this year but to me
it's like which version of came do we
get yeah from I hear it's not the
version we're thinking who do who do
they hope it is my favorite fighter who
did they give him he does not get the
champ right away and we have the same
agent matter of fact he would not fight
the champ right away he because he's
been out so long yeah he would take a
warm-up fight when I put warmth that's
quote still iam top six top eight guy
yeah but the heavy readers are so old
you probably getting more of a you know
you're not fight Steven whatever you're
taking all the time off right not
fighting Francis up to all the time
although if i'm canè i go for I go for
Francis you go for Francis of course
could you just take what did you take
him down steep it come down well here's
an ankle big and I think came finishes
them yeah they beat Francis now Francis
Leslie yeah
Francis clearly has to go he has to go
immerse himself into the best wrestling
camp he should go to either by John
though he needs to just go to Russia he
needs to move to a K or he needs to
adopt kebede yeah adopt could be opted
to be don't live with you full-time pay
his goddamn bill he's dad and uncle yes
throw yourself at their feet and say
please teach me everything and then they
bring in a big grizzly bear like khabib
dude that's right gonna learn like that
that's right now you're gonna go away
for a very long time gonna go out bein
had that weird Legion of Shadows now
Batman broke his back all right up there
that's you you Batman get used to doggie
stomach food living in the mountains
it's not underground Francis yeah nope
this what's gonna hurt the Carter's
gonna take a little bit of hit because
we gonna break your back we got a Humvee
okay break your back like Batman yeah
and we put you on down that tube now
you're gonna learn the ways of exactly
stinkin you gave me runnin Hills not a
lot of women you're gonna be running
hills and then you're gonna be wrestling
all day long did UFC Institute run out
of EPO what the [ __ ] we do it what we're
doing it's not about to janessa yeah how
about that
the James Kim will shout out James
Kimball I love you man you know I'm
always just joking I love everything
about all the fighters do UFC all that
stuff somewhat so when I made that
comment struming people laugh and
obviously the guy has cardio and
wrestling issues sure I'm not being mean
I'm not ever to annex I called the fight
tonight
and he earned that yeah I called the
fight wrong for God's sake and so James
Kimball reached out there was a hey man
cuz I just you know you put that and
then he as a matter of fact we do have
treadmills but the best in the world we
have the wood ways and this and then we
started dealing back and forth he's like
yeah come on and check it out man I know
my dude I swear I'm literally just
trying to make people out I'm just
joking man yeah yeah yeah I said what
you guys do is great it's a great
training as it sure Conor and have
cardio in his fight and sure France ten
but you'll figure it out
listen running underwater is the wrong
way to do it the wrong way
running underwater ain't working right
run on a road the way the box the
old-school boxers did it and also I
would imagine that there are who are the
wrestlers Randy Couture out there but
see this my joke really doesn't make
sense because the USC Institute what
they do is they supply all the things to
get you to the fight as healthy as
possible so there's rehab there's the
the the doctor training campus centers
the ice the cryotherapy there's
therapists everywhere there's its
recovery and make sure you're the best
possible athlete to get you the fight
there's no other place in the world like
this it's state-of-the-art they have all
the experts on hand they have meal prep
they have
nutritionists they have weight cutting
experts they have everything for you
yeah to get the best fighter to the
night of the fight they do not supply
wrestling coach's head coaches striking
time sure that's your you playing in
that circuit you want to do your train
can you they have nothing to do with
that so my joke doesn't make sense it
was funny but doesn't make sense yeah
let's make that clear he goes back to
France I think his training camp is
France the kickboxers in France all
those giant dudes yeah I don't know
there's a lot lot to do there but you
know the heavyweight division is older
but you know a guy like Derek Lewis the
black piece who can't who has a massive
double leg would probably beat Francis
yeah anyone with any experience of
wrestling from elementary school would
beat Francis probably on percent now if
he hits you're gonna be in trouble but I
went when it would not when we say a guy
was exposed yeah and and it's all
learning it's all right it's all right
because you look at the co-main event
with DC and uh who's de mer it's
actually who's de Manos de man so yeah
who's the man when you look at that
loser may have put on a fight yeah you
know I was playing for Keith had great
wrestling takedown defense against DCI
well well world-class Olympic wrestler
out he'd showed you no heart there when
his back at the ground he sees having
assi Ghat finish but I thought he put up
a great fight
who else beats n'gou no DC DC he'd go
right up right now I'm beatin gana DC
Francis oh yeah
DC DC [ __ ] slap something over there I
mean it would finish him yeah hundred
percent what do you think a DC DC steep
a I think that I think that chances DC
steep a hit but happening are so much
more likely than steep a cane yeah
that's that's legit to and maybe I do
too I think it'd be a great test on
steep a steep a is much a lot bigger but
not that much bigger steep a came that
way cut kills DC men it does right hill
it kills kills them yeah
look man I've always said this about
about DC I've said this from there on to
me because I've seen him what he looks
like physically obviously a great
athlete but just he to me is the most
impressive in many ways the most
impressive fighters step in the Octagon
in what he's been able to do
lost twice to the same guy and
everything else he's won and he's taken
on everybody and I mean Gus ISM gave him
a [ __ ] hell of a fight still beat him
so his striking is underrated his
wrestling we already know what that's
about his striking look good he think
it's a great fight I think it's a great
fight with and I and I think we I think
we come down to cardio here's my thing
be what else would you do at light
heavyweight who would you wallet CDC
fight I don't want to see him fight got
me fan awhile I don't see him fight OSP
that's fine I guess Guster's had
shoulder surgery he's out for quite some
time he's out for a while so so if
you're DC and you say 2018 is your last
year fighting it doesn't make forget
like heavyweight oh and not to mention I
know how Jones got to come back so do
you want to stay there and fight sure
time again I'll tell you he's just not
gonna beat I'd like to see DC fight I've
always wanted to see DC fight yo Romero
it's interesting
I've always wanted to see these two
wrestlers go at it you're the higher
level Russell actually I don't know but
I just will never happen though because
you're the middleweight you know but let
me he could probably make 205 but I
think you're gonna see a steep a verse
DC I do I think it's a great fight I
think it's I think it'd be an amazing
way for for DC to DC beats steep a oh my
god oh my god no wonder is he still one
the greatest of all time but if you
ain't steep base to what do you think
happens they're steep base boxing was
very impressive to me but Steve based
power could be trouble for D power but
DC's never lost that a heavyweight
Heavyweight Grand Prix Champion he
picked John I would I would man when the
[ __ ] - top down it's DP I don't know
if cuz I've known are trained them I
don't know what it is
did the DC would be a tough matchup for
steeping well I would say maybe Steve
bacon wrestles ass off he pays a big
deep bass beat better strikers yes but
but this high I think and he can wrestle
thanks I I would I'll tell you why I put
my money on UCS cardio get five rounds
the cardio is give me attitude yes and
you have to give that is such a huge
pressure DC can do for five rounds you
told me yourself you sparred with him he
just keeps coming forward no matter what
keeps coming forward no matter what no
sir I had a chin - granite granite chin
comes from
and if he shot single AG mer there's no
one in your theme could defend a single
light from DC now ain't happening now
maybe John Jones like what yeah excuse
me sir you're not back yet yeah yeah but
you I like the divisions like I what
snakes were steeping he needs take some
time off he needs to take time off after
a fight guys after getting concoction
you got hit a bunch of yeah so you just
take some fight off unless Kane's gonna
come back other than that I really do
you want to see a fight for B so again
seen it you don't see him fight over
again seen it lets you fight Francis now
seeing it I AMA to fight Mark Hunt Cena
I think the DC I think the DC steep a
fight is so intriguing and I think it'd
be the most incredible cherry on the top
of a great Sunday of a career for I
agree brother Wow great fight Wow
great fight gotta catch me up that
Boston card chin the card itself was not
good
the crowd was Restless crowds corners
bored you know what the best fight of
the other card was hurt yeah bat what's
his name no the best fight of the car
was yeah I agree I'm so taters Calvin
cater is a guy from Boston and then
Burgos his guy from the Bronx mano you
know the Calvin cater comes from a
really rich family like haha like super
wealthy like as in he he's so rich that
he bought to fight divisions
he owns promotion have you seen that
man's eyes no first-team cutie pie oh
he's a hundred forty five pounder so
that's about 511 and he's also by the
way he's also a big 45 or he's all
muscle but forget all that I was so
impressed with him because the dude he
fought Burgos had said in a beautiful
striking and amazing head move and I was
you go strides like is anybody watching
this cuz shame but got but got lit up a
little on the feet his he ultimately did
cuz he stood right there and had so much
confidence in his and his ability to
slip punches and come back to I'll tell
you I felt I'll tell you took the
biggest L of the night besides Francis
obviously we know he can't wrestle yes I
know the biggest lol night is that fred
samara Barroso who fought vilayati Gian
John John Daley on tape I felt bad for
John because he was trying to fight and
Mars and whatever judge gave it 28:29
should literally be put to sleep
Wow and I I mean put sleep like a dog
not like that like just put to sleep in
the cold
yeah you should not be working yeah even
John was laughing is like what's with
the solar that was one of the worst
fights I've seen along and that Rob
Thomas I made a fight about went out huh
oh my god yeah
starts down but the card in general not
great right but can we jump over to
Bellator did you see that fight I did
you see all the fights she might blame
your Pico the body shot knockout they
not ready ready I did not see him do
that
the Rudy Nam come on James of MMA do you
see the body shot I'd knocked out 35
seconds he's that part I saw I only saw
cuz I was watching the UFC I only saw
Roy yeah yeah Rory was at a fight on his
hands
Leamas no punk no III gave that fight to
Lima I'll do back I did a few people did
I'll get into that but I'd love to see
the highlight encroaching of this kid
all the body shot who would he fight I
had that matter that same question
let's see if this video works here wow
this is just highlights alright what add
that here it is Oh oh my god I must have
hurt so bad look at this freak
look at that little freak what is he
doing here I don't know Birds Toro the
bull that you know I hear no well he
said listen no one's watching for his
dance was oh oh my god hit him hard
issued I know what I'm doing in my next
street fight how badass is in Pico oh
yeah yeah Chael Sonnen my boy got the
win yes he did nice like a winner Frank
Mir fatal tale chill you know people
forget was maybe they don't forget but
was an Olympic alternate Grieco Olympic
all these people for high levels as long
in the tooth long in the tooth I'll
think it forget long it is but you know
he's loving he seems to be loving
fighting so
yeah so so with the Rory MacDonald fight
you know a couple things that I was
struck by people talk about how big Lima
was and is when he's not fighting and
yeah he's a giant man but God knew how
much freaking Roy God is he good
yeah Roy's too but he's so good in those
low kicks when he and and and there are
a couple times where Rory was making
those shots he reversed got a topper
Rory kicked his leg out when you kick
someone's leg out the way he did
isn't that a knockdown is that is that a
10-8 round tip Emile you wouldn't score
it that way I'm kinda live with it but
uh those kicks were simply impossible
they forced Rory to dive into the double
every time that would happen and forced
him to wrestle Rory's finally a world
champion yeah finally world champion a
lot of people think he's the best
welterweight on the planet and they
think belt or for the first time has the
best fighter in that division and yeah
III what do you think did you think that
he won or did you think the 31 yeah I
thought it was a close fight I knew it
was gonna be a dogfight cuz the FAMAS
entire legacy was riding on he felt
disrespected but you know that's exactly
what out of your title fight I think um
you know Roy's the the kind of the one
signing that the Yossi's done or someone
in the prime like this that's worth the
the salt you know like yeah he's world
champion he went in he had a tough tough
fight against their champion yeah he got
the belt like it's paying off
yeah is there been backlash has there
been a lot of like uproar about that
decision or really been kind of quiet uh
they have so much respect for Rory's
like oh okay well you know I didn't know
got cheated yeah it's different it's
only it's Jens right you know I was
right that's what's only gets cheated on
me yes they're both it's different only
it's cheated look at that pick you you
got to you got two of the greatest I
mean those two you don't get better do
you get better you're gonna guys you're
gonna get a trilogy out of this these
guys yeah that's what yeah yeah yeah
it'll be the ultimate test but I don't
know how do you get better than those
two I mean it as far as complete
fighters all-around mixed martial artist
is ridiculous that's gonna be a hell of
a trilogy I'll tell you that that thing
they found a few times yeah whew
time's gonna take a piss though it's
good let's go to that buddy we're back
from a hot pistol hot piss short a new
podcast we're back his team went back
from a golden shower ladies and
gentlemen that's right
I wept under some piss what did you do
this weekend chin my weekend was not
that great why my motto so we'll pass by
me real quick but my mom's appendix
burst mmm that's pretty bad check it out
it's good to go right no just surgery so
right now we're more like watching her
because she was in the hospital we were
with her for two days in the hospital
and then back at home so we're just
watching for complications cuz she's
older yeah and once it bursts the
changes everything it does really yeah
how old is she
it's 69 70 and not terribly old though
older though so when I mean when you're
a kid it's a probably common surgery but
bursts everything changes because
everything starts seeping in a lot of
bacteria and stuff yeah so how is she
doing right now she seems a little bit
better but we're watching her sorry man
that's a big event we should yeah MJ
yeah nothing really crazy just just
there's nothing crazy we're not being
told all the goods and it's okay cuz
we're just kept out a little loop in the
end of the day you and I are out of the
cool never gonna fight or anything it's
just a bummer
that's alright well good luck with your
mom chip yes sir what do you got brother
for tournament uh first one is a comic
that got attacked on stage I wonder if
you guys know this guy commune Steve
Brown
I don't you don't okay this is the worst
thing I've ever seen as far as an attack
so let me just throw the story you're a
boy so this guy that's obviously rushing
at Steve he was uh just sitting in the
audience and just kind of dull faced and
so the guy the comma goes what's wrong
with you like why are you even in here
if you're not gonna laugh and this guy
just went off on him so the black guy is
the heckler black guys heckler attacking
the black comic okay let's see and this
is the open mic right no no this is his
actual set oh wow in South Carolina
Thanks oh [ __ ] like screwing up so the
god the brown-pants is the attacker the
light brown pants oh [ __ ] he grabs the
mic oh my god
holy shizzle swinging that wasn't like
Stan he's trying to kill him
yeah that's assault with a deadly weapon
which one is the comic the one that's
the one not all blocking it yeah the one
not swinging he's at least standing
there oh dear oh god guy hits he's
defending really well he got mad cuz
that comic is roasted him he just said
like the guy had nervous charity guards
tax on the biggest reason why this guy's
club book club this I know never to go
there
comedy house in South Carolina yep I
know it you do yeah I'm not going there
but yeah okay you gotta get you let's
see what up C Brown here I'm sure y'all
saw the video and I'm good I'm great the
outside of skills you know the dougie
move I did I shot right now somebody's
comedy clubs got to be held accountable
for lack of security I agree that is the
do what are you being heckled he wasn't
be nobody was messing with him me my man
Marlon we were doing a great show and
all of a sudden the dude just got up he
lost his mind I Haxton was the okay and
then he just went they went from there
and I had to give him the comedian
disclaimer did you come onstage
your ass is open gay so you saw what
happened he was doing all that swinging
and I was doing the ducking out and I
was if you look at the video I was
talking to him like dude you don't get
tired I'm gonna knock your ass out God
so he saw he wouldn't get no mix in and
that's when he started picking up you
know the [ __ ] but you know he did
keep his eyebrows moving right up to
Steve Bradley Brown skills I like Steve
Ott Brown sells more tickets me too man
God I was trying to kill a man he was
yeah he was he was trying to kill him by
the way hey a guy that guy's a mess
he also punched the security guard his
way out that dude the crazy guy he's a
gangster who knows it's got a guy that
will
back and shoot you that's a gang boys
that's a dude who doesn't give a [ __ ]
about his we don't like crazy uh yeah
that's not a good guy woman at the the
comedy House said the management would
not comment on the incident yeah you got
a thank God for looking out for me and
give him my old ass the ability to bob
and weave because this could have ended
in a horrible way and he's right yeah he
doing in that slobbin I'll tell you what
men do everywhere I've been Security's
been on it the Wilbur there's some
there's some crazy people who got some
Boston boys in there that's boss small
there's big Boston burly boy are you
handling it yeah though they do not play
no they didn't play that's a bad
situation no Dan God you've seen that
one comic who knocked the guy out I know
Google that from the comics what was it
so the comic oh yeah I have to his
collar shot and then the guy's friend
not egos I'm telling you the same what
you want you come up here you can get
knocked out he's he's roasting his wife
I know that guy I know the guy who did
that topic uh so heckler gets knocked
out yes guy yes yeah this heckler always
would be around to he'd always come hang
out
really yeah he's always at clonic
heckler and the guy is a good guy I know
this guy he wrestles another comic that
comics a good guy he rescues pitbulls
kind of an athletic guy I'm here this B
oh this is one I'm talking about know
what I tend for this guy gets kicked in
the chest yeah he's right employ yeah
he's wearing a 10-4 that's a tough place
for comedy this is nice kick ready
what do we come on he's coming straight
at him dummy so and say come on bro
that's not the one I'm talking about
racist cop knocked out by age no keep
going to that it's if the comic doesn't
not come out it's a heckler gets knocked
out by the security he goes I'm telling
you saying what you want man I got boys
you get up hitting you're dealt with and
they got in the guy goes say one more
thing about my wife or something like
that and he says something like who's
[ __ ] who
like I get to get up and before I even
if the stage this security guard comes
out of nowhere
yeah and knocked him out and then it
gets roasted yeah that's how it should
be the comics gotta be there anyway
fine in Hollywood ah keep going keep it
scrolling keep it's growing
mmm no we don't see it someone a selkie
toast it's hilarious though yeah anyway
it's always rough yeah that was bad
though guy picking up that mic stand
cause he's trying to kill a man alright
a lot of people have been sending me
this during the Hawaii false missile
alert pornhub did a metrics analytics
thing showing how their the people are
watching their site so prior to the
missile or actually one that the warning
came out there's a huge drop in users
right watching porn on pornhub and then
as soon as he found God really quickly
it was a 77 percent below average but
then after they got the okay that it was
a false missile or jack forty eight
percent above average oh yeah oh yeah
there's a drop in Hawaii when we're
gonna die I'm the last thing I want to
see is this poor nut amazing some people
said they don't want the last thing
people to see was that they're on porn
so they all logged on here's the problem
seventy seven percent drop that makes
what's the rest of 13% doing like you
know what I'm just kidding if we're
going out which command it's like the
whole 14-year old you think yeah what's
an old man like if I'm gonna go once he
also Carol one last time it is it's true
but if you get died you don't want
somebody finding your computer I mean
like this guy was you know they'd go and
say I don't think I don't think they go
into all your [ __ ] everything my dad
looks at my my computer hit the history
and he goes yeah he goes why is this
porn porn porn porn point and I was
there I go why do you think
in business he just look amigos
he said Vegas I was like 48 I want to
know the people where to god I don't
watch porn that often neither I really I
swear to got it I very wrong I want to
know the people who were jacking off
even though they thought the world was
gonna end who is just Jack and I send a
lot of people like hey what the missiles
are coming we should probably [ __ ] huh
no condom and everything else will
[ __ ] make sense like a quick let's
hook up real quick before the world ends
but get on your computer and jacking off
alone is that the way you want to go out
I don't know not really I want to be
ready
good yeah god damn dead I want to be
ready for I don't know what I would do
so some guys just some lonely guy in his
mom's basement like if this world can
and I'm just gonna pop up as many nuts
as I can okay dad get exhausted like
take me now take me and then it's a fake
alarm you like [ __ ] well alright dude I
was in college I was at this I was a
counselor at this debate camp don't ask
debating the guys I was rooming I was
bunking with a do that below me he was a
counselor and I just heard you jacking
off Miller Lite
and then he goes wow no way I swear to
God I want man come on dude don't go
yeah Wow
don't do that and that's that debate
nerd [ __ ] man just gonna be jacking off
yeah yeah I'm above you here bro
I don't want to hear you weird
was he like sorry bro no I didn't say
[ __ ] I was like I'm gonna stay like like
you never happened good dad Wow
no sit out loud at 2:00 in the morning
crushes debate the next day minutes is
routine Oh God he likes to bust some
nuts and then my daughter's been waking
me okay every every night cuz she hears
something in the room I'm in a dead
sleep dead [ __ ] you wake up yo why I'm
gonna desert day you have to check my
closet
somebody's trying to get out of my
closet nobody is trying to get out of
her the love of God I'm not the [ __ ]
conjuring I got to go in there she's got
all the lights on my god Jesus your dad
was a military man right yeah so it was
my dad
does your dad wake up like World War
three is happening he never really did
oh my dad if I bike Papa Papa yeah I'm
like oh [ __ ] I'd rather deal with the
monster yeah when your PTSD when I wake
you up man you know what I wake up the
same way I fit really
I've hit friend's girlfriend vo yeah
really
oh yeah I'll wake up swinging so will my
brother dude I don't know what it is I
think it's cuz we're such in shock with
my when we were kids we woke up my dad
he'd wake up they did did you pee pee
stains and all Mouse in his undies just
like my dad moves my my and so I wake up
like that now so it goes Fred Bremer and
direct it well you feel like you have to
protect your family or something right
throwing bows them yeah you need an
early-warning detection I got a yeah get
a stick or poke me or something yeah my
dad used to wake up like he was a
[ __ ] Vietnam vet or some [ __ ]
you're all know but when you're sleeping
somebody comes in that's what they want
I got it Maya our buddy Jerry McFadden
you could never catch him sleeping my
buddies said in college they'd all the
football players no matter what time -
no matter what you were never catching
him sleeping like as in you'd sneak in
like they go they happening they would
try to really quite they just Greek
doormen and every time they'd hear hey
do you have alarm at your house right
yeah my alarm so this was like weeks ago
we sew my alarm we have guns everything
in the house dog right so the alarm when
our guards came Velasquez yeah you
practicing God they're all kind of
cramped Frances in God knows my security
guard but Heffley no wrestlers on the
robotic dog masters breaking up what are
you gonna do him anyways so we'll run
around in rusty what do you see him
stick on top of them no no just like a
bunch of CrossFitters like we're just
gonna run around to your time take you
down anyways so and then steal all
Brendan's stuff so uh we didn't shut the
garage door very good like you would
like it was locked be now sometime it
locks but it sticks against the yeah
like key so the wind picked up in the
alarms on so if any drawers open alarm
so I'm sleeping 3:00 in the morning the
wind picked up the alarm goes off well I
didn't know that I assume someone's
breaking in and you go into Navy SEAL
mode
I got the [ __ ] yep I was so scared
now cuz you think someone just and if
they're ballsy enough to come in there
gangster that's right that's why I'm I'm
here alright
yeah I'm calm I'm in my [ __ ] underoos
with a giant shotgun it's like I came
and I don't want to do this man I'm now
yelling yeah cops come goes well did you
look around the air I go not really I
stayed on the stairs waiting for him to
come out to blast him in the face he
goes giant brightens yeah then they knew
who I am he goes hmm
yeah the next time I probably look
around cuz it looks like the wind blew
out the door open
really he was mad yeah what was positive
that's what happened there's no way into
here just that way
oh man I'm embarrassed that's all right
I like the stories about like there was
that twelve-year-old girl and she would
compete in shotgun like you know those
hips shooting the skeet shooting things
she was like I have national junior
national Chandler couple guys broke in
and they had killed somebody before I
came in and they had bad intentions she
was 12 she was those two men have bad
intentions and they come in they chased
her upstairs she got the old shotgun at
competitions yeah a little
yeah she'll talk dad in case of lead
poisoning him out she played some
Nintendo duck hunt sure did that human
case case bled time on human hunt got
one of them at the top of the stairs and
then another guy was at the doorway so
dude I had this cop when I was having
issues on my house was breaking down how
I should shoot people when they come in
really yeah as all how first of all
you're saying at the top of the stairs
and don't turn the lights on he's my
first reaction sure like Sonny like no
don't turn the lights on that lets them
see what's going on you know the lay of
the land leave the lights off ATS smart
okay
I feel like egos egos you wanna be
higher up higher top to higher ground
the advantage so you stay at the top of
the stairs when they come up whoo boom
another one go boom aaah kaboom okay huh
boom that's a guy Skyler you're scaring
the [ __ ] out of me and you tell me
getting more gun scare I feel like
you're way too serious about things
because my garage door accidentally came
open now we're going through
hypothetical situations in case the
[ __ ] Armageddon come yeah my buddy
keeps crawling I slept
zero that night so I was just sitting
there thinking about all the [ __ ] your
hearts I gonna do as good as get his
heart man I was with a girl I was lying
with a girl in my bed and I just broken
up with my other girl who I used to live
with back then of course that wasn't
dating I was carrying on with her still
carrying on we linger yeah I had I was
kind of having this fling with this big
beautiful girl sweet and but like so hot
like I remember being like ha ha are you
this hot anyway and she was she was so
sweet and she say sweet again at my
house I know I know
if you don't worry you're gonna distract
know I lost my um I lost my anchor the
anchor quite neat metal braces bro yeah
so I know the metal ones won't come on
stop pushing metal braces on me dude I'm
not walking around the containment
Frankie I'm like video problems
don't care yeah so the girl so my girl I
decided my little one but what
two-bedroom cottage so I didn't have a
second floor I'm sleeping with this girl
and I just hear my window and I just
in my dream I hear uh-huh and I wake up
and I think someone's breaking in and I
go I'm screaming at the windows and I
see it's my girl
and she sees that I'm gonna go she goes
oh that's just [ __ ] great you scumbag
piece of [ __ ] game over yeah I like and
I'm even like uh I'm screaming even more
it was a [ __ ] nightmare she just
storms off and get a mugging car I tried
to chase her it was a bad situation a
man that hate beans do you know the girl
who was where I was with said she goes
you haven't let you have a good heart
though you felt bad I was like yeah
we're not even dating anymore but yeah I
guess she has no daddy issues um yeah I
don't like being scared like I out of
ex-girlfriend college get me punched her
right in the face hashtag me too really
let's take me cool boy accident soccer
yeah soccer me right in the shower hate
being scared man
give her the old jab straight to that
[ __ ] day good news get booze why do
you do that why'd you scare me man oh my
god I don't scare me I hate that [ __ ]
I'm also we're too old for that I hit
the wall you ever do that when you're
thinking about fighting your
you're dreaming and you know you do
about to fall asleep with ya good you're
armless get a wife is wait this is her
[ __ ] this is a funny story my wife we
were like first married and I was like
let's get gone she goes now I cannot I
ate too much
I don't feel well I don't want less you
got to fart I go I go no I want to fart
yes you just have you know they full of
gas product yeah
oh my come on let me make it little kiss
a hold on [ __ ] [ __ ] no don't you know I
ain't had the [ __ ] no don't say that
stole your wife had to take me oh no
that's not the point of the story
Oh God no she did not a food
Mediterranean I don't remember
Indian yet indeed okay like a curry and
[ __ ] your favorite curry no so she's
like sleeping and I'm like well you know
what I'm gonna come
jackoff no I'm not doing cuz she's
sleeping no but man she's sleeping so he
came through the old colonel backdoor
you shut me down so I go I'm like well
what a Yankee just dirty although you're
married but you have gross [ __ ]
helmet I'm a lazy yank I'll do it quiet
hand smell like [ __ ] egg rolls oh
yeah so I'm like she's so [ __ ] just
Brian Brian Michael are you guys here's
Brian you're shaking the bed like the
pig oh no I got a mess around
roben you ain't you'll embarrass me
there must been jacking off I was doing
are used in the old memory bank I sure
was
I was doing me I was doing work and I
don't get embarrassed that it out of
drying you're shaking the bed like the
pig - Mexico I was like Jesus
that's just oh I know
well I was messing around have you ever
met well yes I've done having kids now
but have you ever seen one of those for
Turley fraternally Clinic people
fertility for totality are telling
fertility have you ever seen one of them
yeah they'll ask you questions that are
super embarrassing in front of your girl
like how many times you jacking off a
day yeah cuz that has two of your sperm
count yeah the less you all sorts of
weird questions do it how many times you
jack off excuse me that let's let's say
jack off and also can you wait till she
leaves like it's waiting oh where are
you doing it and what time of the day
hey man do you mind I'm trying to [ __ ]
up my wife did you ever remember my
house well you ever did I know you and I
had the house in marvista with that
we're at my separate office Mar Vista no
I when I met you you were living off San
Vicente
oh okay in Brent I used to have a house
where I was a great house by the way yes
it was enormous so I had this house a
two-story and the the the master you
could see the backyard and the bat and I
had this incredible separate house which
was like an office big guest house
turned into good I had a mirror behind
me and I had my desk and so I I got I
gotta go do some work in my office and
by work you don't want to come out yeah
do you want to come up now I'm gonna do
some work and I was like I should just
do some work outside going why I'm bad
I'm not tired so she goes alright so she
goes into bed said hmm she's like okay
so I'm like down there and I'm like well
you can never start work guy I mean I
got work to do but you gotta
procrastinate and and it's always a good
idea I got a boner well I believe it's
before you late night I get this late
night Bo let's say look at what you porn
or pornhub or X and possibilities are in
let's just see I know
let me see what the new videos are
because I just want to do my due
diligence as an American man that's a
yes gotta take a look I'm gonna take a
peek and then get you know at work I
call it kicking the tires
it's called kicking we take the time
it's called kicking the tires take the
tires by kicking the tires I mean I mean
jackoff if I do anything
so all Braga's can go well that looks
like I've got to get involved in fat ass
let me just take a guess
fat ass with a dick Potter percent I go
let me take a look at bad here they
first of all how share ports are let me
pay for your college and let me movie
into my head no I want to reach out to
her your us just beautiful too pretty
why are you not in the car different
bags why do Google want my girl why you
a good why you're a good girl my from
Google to bride girl right I mean this
is I move yet we'll figure it out we'll
clean the place I got a separate office
for you if this couch pulls out no Abed
like suck and nuts
that's all [ __ ] these you can't do porn
like no let me see how dirty you get
because I'm gonna need to do a
psychological assessment of how dirty oh
you're that dairy really what that's
hats a crazy ass well lay your that
dirty let us invite chin over play the
three-finger game so that's all let's
get those three ditches - no I'm gonna
bring out the old three digits now now
why what my pants are hot why is it so
hot from the waist let me give him
something off I know and it giggles so
nice give him some air dancer restrict
that's all I know he's like hey let me
out of here in the next Reese touches
your genitals my dick goes alright well
he's already gone hey what do you watch
and let me let me tell you almost like a
heckler in the periodicals you know what
I want attention you up now I got to
give him attention that's all and I'm
ignoring him and he's like let me the
[ __ ] out he's getting more and more
angry by anger you mean rock-hard yeah I
mean Rockwell should be cats just a
glimpse of that you porn which goes
video suggesting I go I like girls with
fat asses that's all I like when there's
two [ __ ] that's all right now he's
speaking my language saw two [ __ ] and a
fat ass yeah then I scroll down you know
bullsh how'd you know I like the GU girl
stuff it's like you guys know exactly
what I'm looking for what is this about
all right is that officer Kara's best of
I'm gonna
watch them well you gotta take a look at
it you know her that's all make sure
everything's all right
so I checked him with her in a why do I
get to work I get to work because he's
like come on so I'm like alright real
quick because then I gotta get to work
I get some attention yeah you know when
they play yeah well I had a little spy
up in the second floor out there I was
like I don't you jack off well she can
see she looked through the winner she
goes she could see my computer because
it was reflecting the mirror high so she
goes that [ __ ] sees me just go
ahead I mean that's really dry ass T
like black poor so whatever was that's
attractive know how when you're forty
something shitty how they wanna do some
work
oh yeah I'm gonna do some work and not
come up and take care of business she I
just I do it about heads up and I'll
tell us Amanda she's amazing God hold on
for she deserve some sort of [ __ ]
stipend or every month for dealing with
your I machine I'm a piece of [ __ ] you
are she comes in and goes I just hear
the door go gang she just bars are you
serious I can see the mirror
are you serious dead serious because I
don't even know what to say
and she just turns out Huseynov walks
how does I do there so I my that's our
I'll be up in a minute let me finish the
fever help me finish this project waddle
upstairs I'm like hey she goes oh please
oh pillow over the head gross I was like
I got I cried there's a monthly stipend
government policy she deserves a [ __ ]
she should get an Academy Award every
year for doing this it was just a ball
of shame [ __ ] me
what else you ever got caught jacking
off to never luckily yeah yeah well I
have some spies to catch you uh what
else you got these people know who I
really am God cast all right Texas judge
during a deliberation for a trial with a
sex trafficker he popped in before the
jury could say that the person was
guilty he said God told me that she's
not guilty
Wow and he tried to change the juries
mind you shouldn't judge judge he might
have the right to be a judge and then
she was eventually the jurors were like
in shock and everything but they did try
as guilty and then she's serving 25
years in prison
well she must have done some serious
[ __ ] she was trafficking her niece
oh yeah well she should die God told
that judge look at that
[ __ ] creep you know what he jacks off
to ya little boy exactly that's what the
[ __ ] that's a very strange
he says God tells him to do it when that
man has a lot of power over a lot of
people Wow
that means as big as a criminal as the
people he I was gonna say did God child
trafficking case all right wow man wait
Perez was arrested sold the girl then
fifteen to thirty year old man who would
end up impregnating the girl Wow there
were jurors who were physically sick
crying and distraught
his name is Robinson jaw drop Wow Wow
Wow that should be put down and also
castrated and then all she was guilty
then he left
cuz God did it he's a strange dude it
sounds like I think I don't think I get
to be my comply get disbarred for that
hopefully it's a good old [ __ ] you're
just not supposed to tell you that no
judge is not he'll say that judge yeah
you what kind of power those [ __ ] that
he's allowed he tells you what evidence
to look at what you shouldn't look at
that guy's one notch above well Harvey
Weinstein all right what else eunjin um
she shave her head again it looks
shorter I did do it yourself or you went
to a barber I always cut my hair myself
that's why this to the bone how do you
do the back mirror
you fit you fade it use yourself - yeah
damn son you can cut here I can cut any
[ __ ] I need a fade son late for the
Grammys on Thursday you know what my
this room up my stylists about Warren I
love this guy it stops for all these
people yes here's what here's here's why
I'm thinking for the Grammys and I go
please tell me it's not black you know
cuz it going over all blacks is not fun
you sent me pictures merely I thought a
love it it's loud and there's a
turtleneck involved love it but B I mean
it roasted so that's the first thing
my mind is only get roast so bad by
daliyah Rogan and Brian that's right
definitely doing it though all right I'm
gonna post a video calling you guys out
all right I'm gonna say you the idea and
you're gonna laugh your ass off I'm
gonna freak out
yeah I took my stale but you're yeah
you're gonna freak out you know freak
out the only reason you get away with it
is because you're just you're a fighter
I don't know
figures you're cauliflower ears they
work I don't know man you're softening
your edges go on sorry carry on Jenna
nobody's got your own hair have you
never come out here yeah since I was
like in junior high
Brian cuts his longtime buddy [ __ ] it
up I did I got it figure it out
I got all my own hair just now did I did
this morning cuz only you know your hope
you know your grooves in your head
little dips and everything so don't do
it dude I'd rather die yours looked
really good I used to always shave my
head just like that when you stopped
shaving your head you know just infer
the Goldbergs and acting and just
becomes for me yeah yeah I vote here
shave tech stuff for me cuz especially
what I do now look tougher yeah it's a
very chin looks like a criminal let's be
honest I love you you look like a little
yeah he looks like a crema vehement yeah
yeah we had long hair looks like a seat
off-topic yeah he does right like I
wanna mess with chin yeah yeah he looks
tough
do you not so many people asking me in
Boston if you and Brennan are really
gonna balk or box row box like dead
serious right spar yeah not like her T
and then they go how big is chin
cuz these guys are like where do you
think the odds are gonna be much what
like how biggest gentleman he's [ __ ]
big man 6-4 no six to maybe six [ __ ] off
you're not 16 big kid your big boy wide
head white head yeah alright let's go
quick MMA one Dana White said that
Robert would cruise conditions actually
really serious he had staff in his
intestines right around the body super
dangerous man what Dana go said he had
staph infection his stomach from what I
understand it wasn't treated properly
and started to eat away at parts of his
organ in serious condition so it's gonna
take a minute before he's back I think
wow how does that happen so it happened
in two o'clock
happening clop so when you have staff if
it builds up and their systemic it will
it depends where it's at but for a clop
it was in his knee so was on the service
like in between the skin and the muscle
and then something he got hit and it
just pushed it in oh man then he gets in
your blood if he gets in your blood
stream
timeout Marissa their new time you're
gonna start to shut down life that you
can die life that yeah clop was in
serious trouble so he's on me Whittaker
yeah Oh big but if they catch it you're
good like you I'm sure he's amazing in a
box but it's a big deal man
it's a big deal yeah that's really
terrifying Wow the Aziz Ansari thing so
last week there was an article that came
out in the New York Times by a girl who
wrote something saying Aziz Ansari is
guilty of not being a mind reader
a girl named Barry Weiss good for her
and her point was like don't confuse
this stuff with the actual me to MU yeah
it's no problem you guys are actually
hurting your own movement so that a
female that came out with this she's ten
years old is hurting
she's actually hurting the real move and
how about the journalist who is also
like 20 I mean I saw her I was like oh
got it on this no not now no one's
taking serious so what you do when you
do this now when an actual case happens
people aren't take you a serious yeah
and for Aziz it's like it becomes great
one
this is only one award last night the
SAG Awards and they don't clap for yeah
that really bothered how dear you
holding that you should be ashamed
yeah oh but you were clapping for Harvey
Weinstein a year ago you're climbing for
Kevin Spacey for on all his [ __ ] and
house of cards look they don't blabber
Aziz you movement has a lot of positive
[ __ ] to it it's great in a lot of ways
and I think men are put on notice to
kind of like be more aware of their
impact and stuff but you're right this
is a classic example of you're gonna
cheapen the real victims man then and
and what they've gone through with this
stuff not know you don't belong you
don't get to be part of that group sorry
not in this case and I think that you
know I have to say human beings we're
all we all want to be part of something
and and I believe them the art majority
is what I do thank you for holding my
hands I don't only most these women are
I think most of them almost all of my
telling the truth like there's a lot of
truth and I don't think women just make
up stuff but there are people like in
any group that want to be part of a
larger thing and something else oh my
they'll arrest might be mad or that's so
successful oh he does to me yeah have
you read the account it's like yes I
read it I was so confusing like hold on
hmm and it sounds like James Franco
suffering from the same situation right
you know another guy who got a girl
cause he has to show me his breast he s
all shows breath well he was casting
male or female stripper yeah that was
dope come on
oh and I've also been in acting class
for years you get naked in fact one of
the things that the teacher would always
tell you including the me is that you
got to be kind of comfortable with
nudity if you're not we got to talk
about that something's like in piss when
you just go swimmin if you're wet
[ __ ] yes Michael felt like a guy's
good-looking they go take responsibility
for your looks start using them whatever
a woman's good-looking and they go you
gotta get in touch with your sexuality
and you do as an actor with James again
if you read these accounts and I'm not
defend all these accused but when
they're good guys I think someone needs
to defend I'm not that more important
people aren't dependent there are people
are psycho when the the the witness goes
yeah yes we need to take our shirts off
show our breasts if we're not we're not
getting the role and there you go what's
the role and you read more you hold on
you came to a casting call it's part of
strippers yeah and then he asked it
before you take off your shirt cuz he's
casting strippers and you get offended
and now you want to ruin the man's
legacy while he's up for the biggest
word of his life come on you it's
complete [ __ ] no new sunglasses
about goddamn time yeah [ __ ] that that
horrible horrible glasses and I get of
those rain bands yeah I like the man let
me see him onion who told you get him I
was in Mexico on the bottom let me see I
look like blade al about my madam though
well I I moonlight his plate sometimes
yeah dig it I was real quick on this so
did another woman Ashleigh Banfield
who's a host on a CNN and HLN she's also
fashion the girl that the art doc she's
bashing the website that made the
article head back to fashion the girl
that's like on Banfield's up
journalist Pam fields legit oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah good nice yeah because they
know they don't want it they don't want
to cheapen this thing dude I am real
quick how about Matt Lauer's wife kicks
me off Hampton house what took you so
long
how about um we have to talk a little
football Patriots Jags Patriots are back
out again
it'll have anyway back to you don't have
anyone I was actually going for the Jags
I know Boston won't hate me let me guess
I just I'm sinking the Patriots winning
everything but how about the Gronk goes
out of the game they lost everyone to
begin the year they just missing pieces
and then he's still doing the damn thing
that's claim better playing better than
he's ever played before he's such a
[ __ ] monster monster and they there's
just this new piece coming out on you
know Facebook's doing their own original
content and there's a piece called
something being Brady or hanging with
Brady and like behind the scenes with
him and it shows him working out like on
vacation like at his house and his wife
work out and she goes I've never seen
anyone love anything more than that man
less football ever and you and there's a
great quote by Tom Brady in that he goes
if you're gonna try and beat me you
better be willing to sacrifice sacrifice
what I've sacrificed he was life for
sacrifice family fun time everything
just cuz I want to beat you in this game
so if you think you're gonna beat me you
better be willing to sacrifice same [ __ ]
I'm willing sacrifice that goes when it
comes from loves roger federer greatest
of all time loves the game 37 now
playing still at the top of his game
like just loves the game so much it's so
crazy though they're interviewing Tom
Brady after he gets emotional like I
mean you've lost everyone you're here
and he's like he gets emotional now
really Hank yeah I see that huge talent
she was showing you emotions yeah and he
stepped out the interview but such a
monster greatest of all time I was going
for the Jags like the Jax story I think
it'd be fun then I was I it did happen
for me I want I'll uh let's see I like
the egos on that carson wentz even
though they have a backup so there he
goes beat the show the Minnesota but I
thought you know see the Eagles beat the
Patriots I I think he goes might be
favorite maybe well I have to look we
should look at the odd spring up thought
all these heavily up but
so mil i the only reason why I'd
Minnesota win because I thought be cool
cuz the Super Bowl is in Minnesota they
put the first team play in their own
stadium at the super all thought that'd
be cool bike the egos like the story cuz
anyone a super on how [ __ ] long but I
like Carson Wentz he's the reason why I
like the Eagles and he got hurt so they
have this backup foal Souza beast so
they picked the what's the odds do we
know I'm looking at right now belcheck
greatest coach of all time and Brady
greatest quarterback of all time hands
down hands down hands down it's done do
you choose
Brady over Peyton Manning if you're
choosing a team your fantasy team yes
the absolute absolute winner hey you
know Jim try finding after you find the
odds if you just type in Super Bowl odds
you get them
you're on force right now yet but if you
just type in yeah you know Super Bowl
patrialis but whatever John 18 duh Super
Ball odds
should what a Super Bowl two weeks
February
how many more heels open as underdog the
Patriots barely I bet though huh five
point five five-and-a-half not ton of
ton of points usually threes closer game
five-and-a-half that makes sense the
Patriots I'm sure grande could be back
okay look up Tom Brady Facebook show I
want you to see this gonna make you a
bigger Tom Brady fan face and I'm like
on the fence there it is but Tom versus
time typing Tom versus time see if they
have the trailer Tom versus time trailer
I'm a brave fan I like guys who were you
know whose mindset his discipline I'm
not like the biggest Brady fan but I
watched this and it's definitely
interesting as [ __ ] here it is this
isn't it this is this is some lady
talking about it there's the trailer
right here that's right you willing to
do and what are you willing to pay to be
just like me you've only got so much
money and I've got all these protein
bars to sell now let's thank me you
better be willing to give up your he's
going down we gotta find it now we're
gonna have a rare look behind the scene
that the life of Tom well here you go
truth quarterback well he's the star of
a new documentary series called Tom
versus time Paula Faris is here with
more good morning Paul good morning to
you person I'm well there you go go back
go back to the upcoming Tom versus time
docu-series
airing on Facebook watch the five-time
Super Bowl winning quarterback for the
New England invites fans behind the
scenes of his life off of the gridiron
sacrifices the newly released trailer
viewers see Tom Brady playing with his
kids interacting with fans even working
out alongside his glamorous supermodel
wife Gisele
but while the 40-year old quarterback
would prefer to be focusing on the
playoffs it's an explosive ESPN report
detailing an alleged power struggle
between I don't do that gossip I wish we
had the real trailer I'm sure we can
[ __ ] find it I'll find enough fun end
of tomorrow Tom Cruise I love that movie
I didn't see it dying that's a great
movie originally that's it you only
didn't market it right but then theater
no no let's see nope see that see the
trailer for Tom Ray's oh there is that
it no no wow it's so hard
definitely not it
little volume good rewind that let's
kick this off Jamie Jonas 30s the new 20
and Tom Brady is showing us 40 is the
new 30 let's just backyard by the way
where your spirit about me
I'm always in competition with myself
you know I have to say I don't think
I've ever met anyone that loves to do
something as much as he loves football
what I see myself out there I feel like
man I still do this and I do it better
than I've ever been so why should I stop
come on bro dude I love excellence like
that I know how great is that
I love excellence like so Krunk for that
then again I'm not the biggest brady fan
I like him I know this way I'm sorry to
bring it back to the the the guy who
figured out that solve that problem no
but he figured out this problem that
they thought was unsolvable and he said
that he spent like it was he went
through such dark times where he was
sitting there trying to come up with
this idea and he said this his brother
he got so desperate at one point because
he kept he called his mom I got it I got
it and then he would recheck his idea
and it was wrong so finally he goes he
he's been approached his whole life
talking he's Nobel Prize winners and he
goes you know his brothers away owns
restaurants in Boston and he goes I
think I'm gonna quit and I'm gonna go to
my [ __ ] brothers restaurant and try
to get a job as a waiter if you'll have
me I'm done I'm done
and after winning all these awards and
stuff in math and powered through and he
just but but he was just saying he goes
I had to just sit and I would sit there
and I would [ __ ] think all day and I
and I realized that you know obsessing
over one thing there's kind of like this
faith that if you really sacrifice
everything and just obsess over one
thing you're gonna there is a light at
the end of the tunnel like and it's like
when he says I gave up my life like in a
way had to give up his life to figure
and anybody who's done crazy amazing
things it kind of takes all of you and
it is it's a question is is the juice
worth the squeeze man and thank God
there are people like that like [ __ ]
Brady thank God man because it's it's so
glorious to watch that [ __ ] is it close
just one more just that old lady that
sneaks onto or tries to seek and
airplanes
this is the tenth time that she's been
busted people get off on this you expect
they get off on duties something's wrong
with her for sure
she actually made it onto an airplane in
Chicago O'Hare blue to London how does
she get by TSA she's serial sneak on
artists yes she's been caught over ten
times but people love it it's like the
people that break in your house and jerk
off in your closet when you're there and
then they leave it's like a tunnel
I don't know those be my do the Manson's
yes of the Manson Family started by
breaking in your house and moving all
the furniture around so you want any
like what I got off on that they started
off with they're like weird not getting
caught they would break in move all the
furniture and leave your stuff and
people come home like the hell have this
happened and then they started you more
than they started to steal then they
started murder oh my then it got dark
that it Jim that's it all right
Wow Wow you know you come see me this
week in a Columbus Ohio at the funny
bone I love it Thursday Friday Saturday
it's such a great areas that we'll whole
store the market there yeah and then
when you go a homage homage
image Oh Mitch oh my oh my gosh oh
they're all mods take care my boy all
right I'll go how much this weekend I'm
at Columbus funnybone then I'm at the DC
Improv Febrary 1 2 3 the next weekend
Brea improv Bremmer oh yes I'm a brand
propagate your tickets at Braddock
improv I just hit his dick yeah you push
my balls in sorry ok I'm hungry I'm
hungry too man ah let's see
I will Boston you shout out to you guys
that's one I will never forget I will
definitely come back there January 31st
I'm in Denver that's a Wednesday night
Denver Comedy Works downtown the
thursday night show on february 1st is
sold out and then st. Louis is on the
2nd 3rd helium in st. Louis
then La Jolla is end of February 23rd
through the 25th that's basically San
Diego then March 1st and 2nd March 1st
there's 10 tickets left for my stand-up
in Vancouver at Just for Laughs comedy
in Vancouver and then the next night is
live find the kids Brian and myself
that's March 2nd and then then to March
I'm in Tampa and Palm Beach Florida I'm
coming [ __ ] tea practice calm for
Brian and myself get tickets right now
all this is the final kid we're out